was bedeutet das für den verein leipzig
was bedeutet das für die fans dass sie
jetzt der erste bundesligist sind bei
dem es offiziell sein wird sie dürfen
mit zuschauern spielen hallo
ja also ich denke dieses diese
entscheidung ist für die fans sehr sehr
wichtig julian reichelt hatte gerade
davon gesprochen dass es heute ein paar
anrufe vielleicht in der staatskanzlei
geben wird ich habe auch schon die
ersten anrufe bekommen von fans die
wirklich wissen wollten ob das war es
diese meldung und die fans haben auch
noch mal versichert es ist toll dass da
wieder ein stück normalität zurückkehrt
in dieses fußballgeschäft oder die
bundesliga
und ja sind viele fans die einfach eine
sehr sehr positive rückmeldung gegeben
haben und sich einfach darauf freuen
eventuell zu den glücklichen zu gehören
dass sie wieder einsteigen dürfen
nach unseren informationen stellt ist es
ja so dass diese 8400 8500 tickets unter
den dauerkarten inhabern verlost werden
sollen also unter denen die auch
interesse haben hinzugehen weißt du da
schon mehr dass das wird in den nächsten
tagen
dieser prozess wird anlaufen leipzig hat
22.500 tickets dauerkarten tickets
verkauft und aus diesem topf werden sich
auch die zuschauer ja rekrutieren die
dann ins stadion dürfen es ist natürlich
dann klar dass eine gewisse
nachverfolgbarkeit eingeräumt ist und
das ist natürlich auch wichtig um dieses
für jene konzept was ist der klub auch
lange besprochen und lange vorbereitet
hat dementsprechend umzusetzen und ja
eher beleibt sich ist auf diesen tag ist
auch sehr gut vorbereitet ich weiß dass
der klub eben halt auch schon seid
wirklich vielen wochen und monaten auch
tausende liter desinfektionsmittel
gebunkert hat und wirklich versucht so
schnell wie möglich dieses konzept was
was auch auf zuschauer ausgelegt dass
dann umzusetzen
du kennst die verhältnisse in leipzig
sehr gut politik und sport funktioniert
das grundsätzlich gut oder hat jetzt
nicht überrascht dass die politische
entscheidung in der stadt jetzt immer
vorausgesetzt das infektionsgeschehen
bleibt so wie es gerade ist positiv
ausgefallen ist für den start mit
zuschauern
es hat nicht wirklich überrascht die
unterstützung für den sport in leipzig
ist der große reiz dieses traditionell
eine sportstadt sind viel olympiasieger
viele große fußballer zu ddr zeiten auch
schon herausgekommen
und ich weiß dass die besetzung im
gesundheitsamt und auch in der stadt
sehr sport freundlich ist und das
impliziert natürlich den fußball deshalb
auch das interesse hier groß wirklich
nach sauberen regeln zu arbeiten aber
eben auch wirklich den sport zu
unterstützen und diese diese symbiose
als sehr gut funktioniert der verein hat
sich wahnsinnig gut engagiert alle leute
die rund um oliver mintzlaff in den
clubs der gearbeitet haben am sich
wirklich sehr viele gedanken gemacht und
das ergebnis sieht man jetzt dass es
überzeugend war und dass es diese
zuschauer zulassung jetzt erstmal steht